the Joe Rogan experience I got asked a
question on behalf of somebody else hold
on yeah you got a question stored yeah
yeah because I was talking to you no no
no Humber's okay your grandmother yes
named Josie yes Gerard Way yes
lead singer of My Chemical Romance yes
yeah we're related that's who he said I
was like I'm going to Joburg he goes I
don't have a hundred percent
confirmation on this but I'm pretty sure
Joe Rogan is my cousin yeah my aunt
Josie was his grandmother yeah I don't
know him but we're cousins how crazy
that two people in the same family
became super [ __ ] famous and don't
even yeah we don't know each other
that's not you gotta have money's
fascinating he's good yeah yeah that in
plus like you're related yeah well
anyway back to the story so you know I
just I didn't know what I was gonna do
for a living and then there's a about a
few things happened you know if you uh
watching a friend of mine get knocked
out really bad there was a guy named
Jersey long who was this badass Canadian
guy who knocked my friend Larry out he
hit him in the head with an axe kick and
just changed Larry was never the same
again he was always like real tentative
and nervous who destroyed his confidence
and you know he also what we did we
weren't making any money so the you know
these are all amateur fights right so
there was this thing like what am i
doing like why am i why is this my whole
life
why were you doing it well it changed
who I was you know from the time I was
15 to the time I was 21 almost 22 when I
started fighting when I started doing
competitions it gave me a focus and it
gave me something where I didn't feel
like I was a loser right like for the
first time in my life it was something
that I didn't I've realized that if I
focused on this thing and I dedicated to
myself to this thing I could be
successful and that change and hillie
the opposite of a loser be a winner in
most cases where I wasn't before that I
was I was a loser I've just didn't it
didn't have anything going so it it's
cool it was your football like for some
people in high school it's like I found
football I found somewhere it was your
Jesus some people like yeah yes yes I
think that's what people need man they
need uh something whether it's chess or
Jesus or filmmaking whatever the [ __ ]
is right you'll find a thing and you
focus it and you see some success and
you're like oh my god let's go do
something I can do something I could be
somebody I can I can I can do something
that's fulfilling and rewarding and I
know that I'm not a loser
because a lot of it is like confidence
right a lot of it is if you look at your
life and you look at things that other
people are doing you go god I can't do
that he's doing that these people could
do that they're different than me I
don't have confidence it takes doing
something and having some success at it
that gives you confidence to do other
things and Marshall is so terrifying to
me it was so scared of it that it became
by overcoming that and becoming
successful at it it gave me this
understanding that you can do you can
basically do you know within reason
whatever you want if you just focus on
it and you're not going to do it it's
not gonna be immediate you're not gonna
be successful immediately and you're
gonna fail but through those failures
you learn and you go back and you get
some experience and you do it better
next time and that is earlier is just
success training yeah and it's like this
[ __ ] tattoo this is miyamoto musashi
from the book of five rings and in that
book he said something I read it when I
was like 17 years old once you
understand the way broadly you will see
it in everything and that that is that
is if anything that is one of the main
focuses of my life that I think that one
more time so once you understand the way
broadly you can see it in everything
that describes you your seeker my
favorite proverb is may you realize your
own divinity in this lifetime
mmm I saw it on a yoga wall-hanging that
my wife put on my house once and it was
just it wasn't really the message she
intended she just liked I think the
image of Buddha and one day I was
letting the dogs out and I was waiting
by the door so you had time to like
really stare at it and I was probably
just stoned enough and then completely
understood it where I was like
yeah you realize your division this life
to your own divinity meaning don't wait
until you drop dead to find out you were
God all along handing it off to somebody
else and some higher power higher powers
in you huh [ __ ] became a fighter
made him feel worth something my vigor
became a filmmaker made him feel worth
something make manifested he's
absolutely right it's it you can kind of
do anything you can't continue can't fly
without a jetpack right Ron James one on
one yes and Mike Tyson babe yeah yeah
there's things you can't do physically
but there's a lot of things you can do a
lot of things you can get better at and
especially artistic pursuits because the
thing about artistic pursuits is you
kind of everybody finds their own way
and so the shift to me from doing
something that was competition
especially competition with grave
physical consequence really yeah do you
go from that to doing stand-up when I
first started doing stand-up I realize
about okay this could be it like the the
[ __ ] fighting thing there's like it's
a dead end there's no money this before
the UFC there was no money in kickboxing
I remember I'd gotten offered a
kickboxing fight a professional fight
for 500 bucks and I was like what is
that $500 it means I have to train for
six weeks no alcohol
eat eat good run do all these different
things training so far and then 500
bucks at the end of it
maybe brain dam it's like when you see
what porn stars get paid for anal and
you're like what like you would imagine
like don't they pay a million dollars to
do that and they're like oh no you know
five hundreds of one fit to 1,500 sounds
about right
[Applause]